- [Instructor] In many videos,
we have talked about the
makeup of government,
either the federal or the state level.
We've talked about branches of government.
We've talked about checks and balances.
What we're gonna talk about in this video
is how people interface
with the government,
and in particular,
what are the channels that allow them
to communicate their preferences?
So this is the government here.
And of course the government
is made up of people
in the various branches.
But let's say this is
all of us as citizens
right over here.
Now, we're always interfacing
with the government,
or we're always interfacing with something
that the government does.
When we pay our taxes,
we are interfacing with the government.
When we try to,
when we renew our passport,
we are interfacing with the government.
But what are the ways
that we can communicate our preferences?
Well, one very obvious
way is through elections.
Obviously we can vote someone in,
we can vote someone out.
We can tell the government,
are we happy with what they've been doing
or are we not?
What issues are important to us
and which issues are not?
Another institution that's considered
a way to link the citizens
or the people of a country with
its government is the media.
Is the media.
And I'll actually draw
a two-way arrow here,
because it's a way for the government
to communicate with everyone else,
and it's also a way for views
to be heard and amplified,
which the government might take note of.
And these things would
influence each other.
Obviously the media is capable
of influencing elections.
Now, another way is interest groups.
Another thing that we have
talked about in previous videos.
So this is interest groups.
And it could actually be
a two-way arrow where...
Let me write this down.
Interest groups.
And we could be talking
about groups like AARP,
the NAACP, or the NRA.
People could be members of that
or contribute to that interest group,
and they are going to
lobby the government,
they're going to try
to influence elections,
they'll oftentimes
participate in the media,
and interest groups are
also going the other way,
where they're trying to get their members
to go in one way or another,
to adopt views of the interest group
or maybe influence elections
in ways that the interest
group might like.
The fourth major channel for the citizenry
to have this connection
with the government
is through political parties.
Political parties.
And these four different ways
of connecting the government with people,
ways for the people to
communicate their preferences
to the government,
these are often listed
in government classes,
and collectively, they're
known as linkage institutions.
Linkage institutions.
And they're called that
because they link people
with their government.
But what I'm gonna focus on
in this video in particular
are political parties
and the roles that they play.
And we're all familiar
with political parties
in the United States.
The two major political
parties are the Democrats
and the Republicans.
But what do they fundamentally do?
How do they play this role
as linkage institutions?
Well, the parties will
have their platforms,
so each of your political parties
will have a party platform.
And I encourage you to do a web search
for the party platform,
the Democratic platform
or the Republican platform.
It's really interesting to read,
especially when you see
how 180 degree opposite
the two different groups can have
on some very similar issues.
But it's a way of saying,
what do they believe in?
And once they articulate this platform,
it can have multiple effects.
It can influence the members of the party,
because common citizens
indeed do become affiliated
with various parties.
But it could also
influence the politicians
that are members of that
party in government.
So it can affect both of those.
Related to this idea
of a party platform influencing citizens
is this idea of voter
mobilization and education.
With an upcoming election,
they'll go to people who are either
already members of the party,
who affiliate with a party
or might be sympathetic to a party,
and say, look,
here are the big issues that
are going to be affected
by this upcoming election.
Don't you care about it?
If you vote for the other person,
these things are going to go against you.
Let's educate you on
our view of what is good
for the local government,
what is good for the state,
what is good for the country.
Political parties also
do candidate recruitment.
A purist view of parties is, look,
they care about changing the agenda
or preserving an agenda,
and so it's really important for them
to field candidates that are capable
of representing that agenda
and capable of winning.
If they don't do that,
the political parties will
eventually become irrelevant
because if they don't have
actual people who win elections
and get into government,
well, they'll also probably
start losing followers,
because people don't like
to be part of a party
that really does not have much influence.
And so political parties
are always going out there
and saying, okay,
the opposition party has
a candidate like this.
Here are the big issues on the table.
Let's see if we can get a candidate
that can really take
advantage of the circumstances
in that region
and has a high chance of winning
while at the same time really representing
what the party believes in.
A fourth thing that parties will do,
and this is related to
candidate recruitment,
is campaign management,
where you will have professional
political operatives
associated with political parties,
and they'll go from,
they might be involved even
in the candidate recruitment,
but once they get those candidates,
they'll say, hey, we're
gonna help you win.
Now, a fifth major function
of political parties,
at least in the United States,
just as these arrows
from the party platform
to the general electorate,
this is really,
this right over here really
is that voter mobilization
and that voter education.
This arrow right over here,
where the party platform is
influencing the government
as it operates,
a lot of this happens
through the committee
and party leadership
system in legislatures.
You have roles like majority party leader,
majority party whip,
minority party leader,
and a lot of what they are doing
is trying to take that party platform,
what the party wants done,
and make sure that all of
these folks in government,
who not, who,
just like the citizenry,
don't always believe the exact same thing.
They might be representing
very different regions.
They might have different personal views.
But to try to bring them in
line with the party platform.
And the idea is that if
they unify around things
and have a united front,
that they're going to have more influence.
Now, of course,
that can sometimes go the other way,
where both major parties are doing that,
where it's all or nothing,
you can get to a situation of gridlock,
which we've talked about in other videos.
But the big takeaway here,
the common classification
for the institutions
that link the people to the government,
linkage institutions,
that allow individuals to
communicate their preferences
to policy-makers,
are elections, the media, interest groups,
and political parties.
And political parties in particular.
They have a platform.
What do they represent?
They mobilize and educate voters.
They recruit candidates
and manage their campaigns.
And then once those candidates win,
they have this leadership structure
that tries to get them to be aligned,
especially around that party platform.